hi
oh hey hey
what's up
um so in case you forgot my name is Jess
but you can call me Mommy
[Laughter]
I'm a very polar person so I don't think
I should be in the front because I'm
more polarizing
but I feel like when you have a huge
personality you're more gravitating but
it could be scary too you know what
though you give like a very like sensual
sweet music
[Applause]
watching music videos so like they're
like oh my God the girl of my dreams I
think you should be first yeah I think
you should be first yeah
wait guys guys we don't have to finalize
it now let's just start watching people
let's start tossing around you're not
laughing you are not last I'll tell you
right now you were doing Naruto runs
around the room no I'm like uh okay this
is hard because you're really funny yes
and you're naturally dating too
um
just for the record I don't think I have
rizz I would not have ranked myself
where I was at but we have to think from
if we can the most we can't think from
you guys perspective who's the most
approachable
if I like a guy I'm avoiding eye contact
if I don't find a dude attractive I can
go up to him and be like hey like what's
your name the moment I find a guy
attractive I'm like oh my God like so
like no eye contact ribs because I get
nervous you know what I mean
if I'm in a bar okay I'm like hi my name
is jazz I just thought you're really
handsome and introduce myself
I don't go to a guy and be like Oh
directly you're handsome I'll try to get
to know your psyche like get you to open
up next thing you know she pulls up the
tarot cards all right I'm gonna do it
and then see if you're gonna crack I do
the psychological game I think we're
good here okay
how's everyone feeling no no yeah
because we're getting raised yeah it's
absolutely I've never been nervous
before in my entire life
that's good have you guys ever been
raised by a girl no no not really no
yeah it's like the little little side
eye like they walk they look at you and
they keep walking this is up to you
girls don't have rhythm I've never like
maybe they'll have their friend come up
or something but you know they're not
they they got the little brushes they
just like some of this
is there something they could do that
would be an immediate turn off and El
risk trying too hard overconfidence yeah
trying too hard like too much are you
thinking how many dudes you approaching
yeah it's like that yeah like if they
come come at me twerking I'm like okay
I think that would be cool and I was
about to say they're coming I would be
okay that's cool I'll take it I'll take
it I think if I they just talk to me and
there are like a few things that I don't
like interests and stuff if they start
talking about like nfts or I'd be like
what are you talking about so Errol and
uh you guys are both on this episode
last time we're here yeah how are you
feeling be on the opposite end I'm
excited you know I'm nervous for the
girls to see what they're gonna do but
I'm excited this time we're getting
Roots I feel like I'm it's like a spa
day yeah we're just chilling right now
watching the first episode of like guys
racing girls I was like
I hope girls are not like that because
some of them you know guys be saying
some weird stuff sometimes I mean I'll
be able to take you from the Volvo to
think on sync them back to the Volva if
you know you know hi how's it going hi
I'm Amara hi I'm Errol nice meeting you
were you nervous
for her where are you from may I ask uh
originally from Philadelphia but uh I
kind of grew up all over yeah you
um I'm from Chino Hills
um yeah can I just say your eyes are so
pretty thank you yeah they're like
literally shining and I'm so sorry I
keep on looking at your hands they kind
of look heavy yeah would you like me to
hold them for you
oh I like her so I like her being said I
like her right what are we doing after
this we're gonna go eat have you watched
lalaland before I haven't oh neither
have I but watches we could go to like
the observatory have a little picnic you
know
like that okay yeah I like her she's
nice I like her
delivery
[Applause]
almost raised through him and to us
hey how you doing
okay okay
you're looking real good today
how you doing no you're so sweet hey how
you doing I'm doing good you look good
though you look good too thank you I
like the blue
go for it
you smell good too thank you
okay
I like to I'm gonna I'm a MMA fighter so
I have to train a lot so I'm training
every day so you know I can protect you
I'm down for it Erica and Garrett we're
getting it on it was actually getting
hot I was like oh my gosh the way she
like did a little spin he was smelling
her it was a lot what do you like to do
I like to watch anime and cosplay anime
yeah so I just dressed up as like any
little anime character can I make a
couple of special requests yeah okay
cool I'm gonna get you some requests
later okay I'll definitely dress up for
you nice to meet you nice to meet you
too give me a hug I hope it's two
minutes I feel taken care of with you I
feel taken care of with her of course
that was exciting hi hi how you doing oh
you stay for the hug nice to meet you
what's your name my name is Ivan and
your name is okay yeah are you from L.A
I'm like I say I'm from L.A because it's
easier but I'm from like out east oh
really I'm from out east where like
people don't really know like the cities
where is out east I live in Chino Hills
oh okay I live in Chino Hills do you
know where that is no I'm Canadian so
I'm like Chino Hills just flew in
yesterday oh yeah just for this so
you're not from here then no damn she
said long distance maybe you're just the
lucky one actually I live in New York
though so damn I was in New York last
year really why did you hear me out I
didn't notice where I dm'd you last year
oh did you didn't see it maybe you
should do me again
um are you doing anything after this
um actually not I might need a tour
guide wouldn't want to get lost you know
okay she's good okay she is good damn
can I get your number absolutely I mean
if I have my phone
imaginary phone okay all right well I'm
gonna get back to my girls but I'll text
you
[Music]
Hi how are you I'm good Jimmy I'm Aurora
nice to meet you
are you from the area
yeah
okay okay I'm from Redlands you don't
want to drink no what do you what do you
like to drink what do you get to drink
uh what do I get to try I get to drink
Mojitos Mojitos yeah stop because that's
your favorite oh we might be
that is my favorite I always go for
mojito okay I feel like people who go
for mojito or like they like them it's
like rare it's like you like you like
the spice of life like you like things
that might be a little bit more out of
pocket eccentric out of pocket so maybe
you're spontaneous a little bit yeah
yeah it is super yes yeah yeah we could
just get line them up with Mojitos back
to back let's see let's see who gets
wrong faster down yes okay I feel like
I'm doing the root no you're I know I'm
like okay I'm trying to get to know you
right now yeah you should keep you
should keep going yeah I know I um I
love Mojitos what else do you like to
drink
um
orange juice all right okay like like
Sunday morning you were doing this when
when you said that you're from here so
are you like
oh no I'm from New York originally oh
you're from New York yeah I've been
wanting to visit there okay so yeah have
you ever been in Brooklyn but Brooklyn
Manhattan all the boroughs yeah so
you're gonna take me around so do you
travel a lot or oh yeah I travel a lot I
got my uh Amex cards okay
yes
and nut let's go Redemption art
we're supposed to be at a bar again
we're at a bar again
I'm the clammiest hand right now
hi
oh hey hey
what's up
um so in case you forgot my name is Jess
but you can call me Mommy I'm not no I'm
not gonna
it's okay I just got I just gave myself
the egg too it's okay glad we're on the
same page we are what's up how's it
going good how are you doing I'm doing
great
[Music]
um
did you have a bad day
no I've been having a good day actually
um one of the better days
do I like bad girls like in like a what
kind of way like a detention no I got a
uh ticket once because I was playing
Pokemon go well that's in the car while
you were driving no I wasn't driving how
do you get a ticket when you're not
driving well I pulled over to catch a
chart so you were in your car driving
yeah but it wasn't on the gas okay well
if you were still driving but it was
really naughty and then I also had
tinted windows so it was like double
down so dangerous which is all around
that's also though unrelated I also just
got a car ticket is that right 70. I'm
not grumpy I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
actually feeling really good it was like
flirting with a soggy towel even like
even being salty with him I still set
him up for jokes and I was like you're
giving me nothing so my love language is
gift giving I like receiving things did
you bring me gifts just in case you rizz
in the bathroom before
Okay so
thank you I'm gonna be bringing I'm
gonna give it back to you
the tissue no but I thought it was funny
maybe next time I see you now that I
know you a little better I can bring you
a better gift
for sure
thank you very much okay I thought that
was fun
I mean no I'm not
I'm sorry I didn't I didn't think I was
being mean my bad
I forgive you I thought we were having
fun I Don't Mind If I Do hi my name is
jazz Jimmy I thought I would just come
introduce myself I thought you're super
handsome I know you're with your boys so
you know I don't want to interrupt
whatever you guys are creeping right now
look at it looking over looking over us
but um I thought I would come introduce
myself and let you know I exist and oh
um you exist already right in front of
me right right in front of me uh what
are you guys celebrating tonight uh
uh Hanukkah it's my boy's Hanukkah
um yeah yeah you know it's just uh we
don't we don't typically go out on
Hanukkah but yeah yeah it's no it's
tradition actually right yes I just
don't get invited Eighth Day okay good
day anyways
um
I would like to take you out sometime
show you how I roll okay how do you roll
what do you roll them to you have to
come and find out all right it's gonna
find out okay so so let me find out then
hold on yeah we'll put my number down so
I can find out
yeah take my number down so I can find
out
yeah
what do you want me to say my name is
huh
just take a picture
I'm gonna put my name as baby baby baby
we're getting into it
I got us Instagram so I don't know he
was nice thanks
in there I don't know I guess I'll have
to find out okay
don't go giving it to your boy since
then no no this is just for me you don't
call me huh you don't come oh absolutely
right after the show all right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah the the YouTuber wasn't it oh the
Canadian my my my yes let's chill I just
kind of like normal right it was like
chill it wasn't awkward I still feel
like his girl was first she was pretty
good she smelled good yeah she looked
good I will be fully transparent I
thought everyone was like good and I
don't know how I would distinguish any
of them or I was just distracted I'm
very easily distracted I saw like a fly
and then I was looking at the Fly for a
second and someone was talking I don't
even remember who's talking Jazz
I'm thinking if that happened to me in
public and she came up to me with a
napkin and was like because you jack off
too much I would be like oh maybe
because I didn't get the reference I
didn't get the reference
yeah in the last video I was like I
raised in the bathroom before and I I
raised in the bathroom beforehand also
and so then this time
it implies that I was like masturbating
in public right which I don't that you
weren't no I know I'm just saying if a
girl came up to me and was like do you
need some tissues yeah
right here okay we got it yeah okay okay
we're great let's do it cool tell no do
it again okay there is something there
is something behind the camera with this
weapons no I woke up this way with the
blindfold I don't know where I am I'm
walking through this room
and watch our videos they're saying you
have to promote our videos
I was locked in a closet
[Music]
Aurora
I got last place yeah well here this is
the explanation it was okay so it was uh
we love the confidence it was great but
it was just kind of like overbearing
yeah it was a lot you know it's just
okay yeah it was a little strong okay
okay I thought I'd be in the middle you
know so we're somewhere cute in the
middle I was like oh yeah I'm gonna be
the top I didn't think I was gonna be
the best next who's next
here's the thing I think you're great
I'm I've appreciated our relationship
together uh so I was I was thinking
about it as if like we're in a bar if
some if a girl came up to me and was
like do you need a napkin for your jizz
in the from the bathroom I would be like
first of all I said rizz I was like I'm
not a predator okay
all right
um
you're you're next yeah
fourth place
I mean it was cool you know to like take
say you're gonna take him out on a date
you know yeah we didn't like that I like
yeah that was pretty good you know
because you wanted to take us out you
know recognizing the boys too right it's
a night out you know yeah that's yeah
that's real you did good
third was a third was mine third was my
yeah my yeah
my you did great you did great mind it's
just that's why you did great calm it
was cool it was good you played the bar
scene good you you were like in the roll
you know I believe and you asked for the
phone I'm not even like legal to go out
guys so that was real improv okay
you never go
I don't go to the bar I can't get in
second and then you guys just swap
places yeah yeah one or two years you
both did great Erica you did great you
smelled wonderful made me feel real good
and now we did like that yeah no we
liked it America took good care of me
because she smelled good she looked good
she did a little 360 around me that
caught me off guard but I liked it I
love Garrett Garrett smells actually
like really nice yeah it was like it was
going 1A
um I'm just happy that I didn't get lost
because my little brother grilled me if
I got lost he would just own me
yeah number one killed it yeah he killed
it it was all natural definitely
confident uh yeah Ariel started falling
a little bit yeah I know I was like yeah
I know at first and we're all like oh
yeah Harold would you grabbed her number
a few oh no of course yeah I'm grabbing
it after oh okay y'all still like the
best six out of like a hundred women
though you know
yeah
I expected like a lot less y'all came in
with the hits
because most girls wouldn't even try to
race exactly
if a girl wants to try to risk not do
you have any advice for them
I just feel like normal just come up be
like hey and I'd be like what's up yeah
favorite number yes
five one
let's watch the number one I like your
nose by the way thank you of course
they're kind of over there but I like
them all right